[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
[Music]
yeah
two commissary cigars we're here
um Joe list first time maybe who knows
on the um
YouTube series I don't like how close we
are yeah
I think we're gonna kiss it does
um Joe yes here's the show when you
should be doing some of these on your
own
um it's two Comics yes two cigars great
is that like gonna hit us too much
uh clouds maybe it's a little annoying
but I'll look over here okay
um
so we're picking two cigars in honor of
your first movie you ever made
Feature Feature what does that mean well
I've made some shorts oh right right
okay future length movie you've ever
made favorite [ __ ] Hollywood douche
wow that was the bit and then you didn't
go with it but I was in a Henry Phillips
movie oh that's good but this one I
wrote I produced and the Fourth of July
every single idea was mine saw every
joke it was great in it I thought to
celebrate a great [ __ ] thing every
joke you made you know Louis was going
laughing along with never even yeah
never even said a thing weighed in it's
crazy it seemed weird seems like hey
you're right here man can you just like
weigh in on this yeah you just slept
nothing to add interesting these ashes
gonna blow all over us any moment let me
show you it might be funny it might be
funny
um
so I thought why don't we have some nice
ones a legit nice cigar and get a Cohiba
yeah what do you mean you look nervous
no I'm not nervous I'm excited to smoke
a [ __ ] beautiful Cupid cigar with you
I just hate lighting a cigar in the wind
okay you want to go off camera and do it
well we'll figure it out I mean I feel
like I always suck I look like a [ __ ]
oh I did notice a lot of [ __ ]
comments about how you don't have a lot
of cigar
the comments I hate the comments the
comments are always bad I keep getting
this comment people like Joe list just
complains constantly I'm like is that
not what comedy is joke and complaining
is that comedy are people like oh you
really care about this you're like no I
try to do a bit about that people I'm
like his whole special is just
complaining I'm like what kind of
special would be hey I'm doing really
well uh I got a good relationship with
my wife I got laid earlier and uh I
enjoy driving good night
um that's comedy that's comedy you're
supposed to make friends I heard Jay
Leno once say that um they're like how
come you don't talk about your wife on
stage and he goes all comedy is putting
things down and I have no interest in
putting my wife down so I don't include
her in that yeah [ __ ] that
it's a guy who constantly puts his wife
down in bits oh that's so sweet that you
would think that I hadn't thought of
masturbating
um
oh God all right here we go Cohiba
do you brown it do you do the thing just
pop it yeah but you can't you can't say
yeah
if you hear it I generally think that's
a good idea I just saw a video on why
that why that works it's supposed to
seal the [ __ ] the thing to the thing
you're doing a great job who the [ __ ]
says Joel is not a [ __ ] minus cigar
I've never seen a light like that what
are the best Lights I've ever seen I
smoke a lot of cigars folks I shouldn't
smoke less
but I think it's good for you have you
heard my theory about three stars think
about everybody's my mom who's who is
synonymous with cigars to you I bet they
died in their 80s guy George Burns lived
to be 100 years old Mark Twain
late 80s uh-huh uh Bill Cosby still
alive still alive uh Church Hill Gabby
potato who's that uh the chick who died
uh hiking in the Zion but she had
murdered nothing to do with cigar [ __ ]
her oh I gotta remind me I have a topic
to bring up to you that I'm interested
in hearing what you think
um who's the other one George Burns
somebody's who are yelling at the
[ __ ] phones or laptops right now
George Burns Mark Twain Bill Cosby
um
old I thought Mark Twain's more of a
pipe guy
pipes
I told you when I saw Bob would pull out
a pipe one time I said this is gonna be
a problem you're gonna have a [ __ ]
thousand he did immediately he had like
300 pipes
um
who's the other I love you Alex cigar
guy they immediately just throw it in
something else
red Arbok he's like the most cigar
basketball Legends one basketball legend
no the addicts yeah I'm like that with
Starbucks tea cigars [ __ ]
can't stop slurping on it love it I'd
love to eat [ __ ]
um that's nice it's nice dude
if I can find Cuban cigarhiba from what
does it say Habana Cuba Habana this is
where I'm an addict I've taken two poles
off of this I'm like what are we smoking
after we get like a nice little one wow
enjoy the moment yeah you ever hear of
Jonah rayza and enjoy your burrito no I
don't know General oh I think he told me
some [ __ ] before I'm Fair uh what
was Jonah Ray he said it was the deepest
depression he was just like the only
thing that would bring him any Joy was
the one burrito from the place nearby
I'm in Silver Lake and then while he was
eating he was like this will be done
I'll be back to depression and then
he'll tell himself like
take that moment in at least I think you
told me that on my podcast mindful Metal
Jacket which doesn't really exist
anymore but it's coming back you stop
doing it I took a break and then never
came back can we just do like a podcast
like is that allowed to a podcast like I
don't want a month or so uh Hey seven
months later I want to do another
episode this is a zoo one this is the
argument with Ron on because the podcast
I listened to
is I listen to waking up with Sam Harris
and Barry Weiss is honestly a podcast
and they come out when they come out
they come out when they have a story or
an interview and I'm never like this
what the [ __ ] yeah it's an hour late it
just comes out I'm sure they get that
though right hey how come where's the
new one also when you train them to like
this is the way it is like you ever work
a black room and then they go like never
I used to but they start like oh eight
o'clock shows like hey it's 8 40. what's
the problem it's like oh crowd I don't
get here yes you're like but you've
showed them how to be like that there's
a lot of clubs that do that let people
show up and they miss the show you
missed it yeah
this episode of two Comics two cigars is
brought to you by zipx toothpicks guys
let's say you want to quit smoking I'll
get there Ernie but a lot of people
can't smoke cigars a lot of cigarette
smokers and other smokers can't smoke
because they inhale they get a head
brush so everyone quit smoking but you
can't you need that nicotine you need
that nicotine Rush where else are you
gonna get it but Civics toothpicks
everybody oh it comes in many flavors
some with caffeine
this one's sweet whiskey it's got three
milligrams that's right I got one of my
mouth right now surprise surprise
civic's toothpicks it's a way to quit
smoking
why not go to zipx tooth that says
z-i-p-p-i-x toothpicks cks.com use promo
code already check out you get 10 off
your order that's a sizable amount
it's two cigarettes out of a pack right
off your order
zipx toothpicks everybody
quit the only way you know how by having
some oral oral fixation there's a third
option but you don't want to go there at
all some of those have a zip energy B12
and caffeine too so get all sorts of
flavors add zipx toothpicks.com promo
code already check out now let's get
back to the episode Ari shaffir Joe this
smoking a kohiba what was I going to say
yeah we need to be able to do that a
little bit just the occasional thing
kind of like two Comics two cigars
damn this is smooth smoke bro very
smooth dog
yours was non-ironic and I think mine
was ironic the Bro yikes we got bogeys
just like oh it's like a it's the last
Fourth of July party same stuff speaking
of Fourth of July well it's probably out
of theaters now yeah but it's streaming
right now Louis ck.com go check it out
if you haven't already dude it's a good
movie well thanks buddy I choked up at
the end I'll tell you what I didn't tell
you or Louis this
I went home to see my parents
a week later
and I was like I had to tell them how I
felt oh wow yeah not in a bad way not in
the like I don't want to give anything
away but not in the movie way right but
like so tell them like they've been
supportive and like really have like
helped me through a lot of like
tough things and it's like important to
talk oh that's nice I do have good
parents so like why not say that yeah
that's interesting and didn't your dad
just do Kilimanjaro I was just thinking
about this talking about it yeah is that
true yeah how is he so healthy what does
he do
uh well a lot of Holocaust Survivors uh
live a long time and I think it goes to
show you the importance of a of a diet
low in trans fats
um
these people trained early on and had a
no nothing all right
I wasn't even sure I was like it was so
Earnest I was like all right I guess
this makes sense I don't know he was in
the Israeli Army he's [ __ ] I don't
know he gets up he's just like
regimented I don't know and luck too
what a [ __ ] answer I mean what's he
doing day to day is he meditate does he
do karate does he eat salad no Gardens
something that's sad yeah it's okay
doesn't drink but did for a while
okay
um spiritual guy religious religious for
sure
right yeah praise three times a day oh
wow yeah standard
interesting and he's in his 80s yeah
he was the when he did it inclined my
calendar he was the I think like the
seventh oldest person to ever do it wow
and he was older than like
I mean he never set the record but he
would have set the record like 20 years
ago
if you've done it you know what does he
rank amongst judiest top five I imagine
probably top five yeah oh so here's what
I want to ask you about there yeah what
do you what's your theory on this so
are you a curb guy Your Enthusiasm
dropped off but I do love it no not a
bad word to say about it but but I don't
I haven't kept up all right so this is
an episode years ago the the weatherman
where Larry realizes the weatherman is
predicting rain so we can have the golf
course to himself wow
funny great show
so Sarah and I were out in Whitefish
Montana incredible pictures you had from
there yeah it was awesome jealous oh it
was awesome we were outside early game
was sick I know I got to play WoW dress
first base coach pretty cool really it
was awesome
yeah that was cool you how do they let
you I'm sorry either after or before I
gotta find out about the first base
coaching before or after what do you
want to do what you do is do it right
now I mean what you realize is the first
base coach is pretty meaningless gig
they literally handed me at home they're
like get out there I'm like all right
because you can see where the ball goes
you decide for yourself I gotta haul it
to Second or not there's some
responsibility you gotta yell through
you gotta let us coach you got the play
behind you you better know did they feel
this right third base coach is huge huge
because you have to know the signs also
you got to give relay signs uh like like
the sign like bunt take hit and run [ __ ]
and then you got your you can be the
goat I mean you can be which by the way
goat used to be escapes used to be a bad
thing yeah yeah now it's greatest of all
time which is stupid but also now they
do like he's one of the goats he's a
goat he's a goat he's a goat and it's
like everything loses meaning within a
year it's horrible like canceled was
like oh that just means you got in
trouble or violence what violence
silence is violence you're like it's
literally not violence disagree
[Music]
uh do you guys feel that violence right
there I could I was getting I got a
little violent with you like words can
be violent I'm like no they can't they
cannot sticks and stones in some ways
may break my bones that's right but
words will never hurt me actually the
words that one's right that's wrong
words can hurt you it doesn't matter
yeah
but any jizz so I was the first base
coach and you got to yell back there
wasn't a pick-off attempt because when
someone there wasn't but you go back
that's fun yeah by that time it's like
too late they got to be making the move
back they're watching anyways but you do
have to yell through you gotta let the
runner know that the ball if you hit the
ground ball that it's through so we can
take a turn instead of running straight
so he hears you behind him
no like he's right like the play is over
there yeah so he's running and I can go
it's through it's through so then he can
round first oh instead because he's
hauling it with it he's not looking at
it at all he's just looking at first he
doesn't have to run past so I can go
it's through and then he can take a turn
or or he knows where it is
um so this fun things like that but I
had two guys hit triples in the inning
which was fun I got the record I got the
uh the audio and I'm going you're good
you're good you're good go go go which
is fun great did you get to keep the
Jersey
no it's it's like an unaffiliated minor
they have no money they make the players
make 1200 bucks a month dude I'd say
Flaming Lips and he gets he got
everybody uh Jeff Ross in Montreal he
gets everybody in um not everybody but
some people in Dorothy Tin Man and
there's Cowardly Lion outfits where's
the film from the crowd wizard popular
movie where those characters came in and
uh he gets them on stage they just dance
the whole time it's so cool looking oh
that's fun yeah and then afterwards like
hey I need those I need those so anyway
change out of those and yeah of course
um but we were in Whitefish which is
spectacular great town tourist but it's
one of these towns I think that's like
blown up it's like cool people town now
so how does this cost a million dollars
like they said the housing market went
up 80 in five years or some crazy number
Angeles
oh you heard that no I never heard that
they're like keep that [ __ ] away from us
wow interesting well anyways it's it's
at like the entrance of the Glacier
National Park but evidently there's only
one entrance into Glacier yeah so we
kept hearing you can't even get in don't
even try you're [ __ ] you can get up at
5am or you needed reservations it it it
[ __ ] uh what do you call it um uh uh
uh not stop Gap not not yeah um funnel
funnel funnel cake
funnel of Love
um yeah it funnels whatever that's still
not it though it funnels it's no it's
like a stop up or something it's like a
cork
it's a stop Gap I just had it on the
Queensborough Bridge how about uh three
lanes down to one another like a drain
it's like a
the [ __ ]
it's
a
bottleneck bottleneck bottleneck so
[ __ ] rewarding to not look it up yes
bottlenecks and we did it together even
if you got it I felt like we would have
got it yeah we got it together
absolutely yeah absolutely so it
bottlenecks anyways you should be like I
forgot the story but anyway everyone
kept telling us don't even try so I was
like all right Jesus well I guess we're
[ __ ] then I was like what if the town
just got together and was like hey just
tell everyone that they can't get in
smart it's not bad they did that with
the Hollywood Sign they put up real they
go to the sign makers like the ones who
actually make the the government signs
you know the ones that are on the street
and they made an official looking signs
said not this way to the Hollywood sign
the Google Maps is wrong because they
don't want people driving through their
property through their neighborhoods wow
all these [ __ ] tourists drug addicts
and such but then I had this thought and
let me know where you come up with this
okay
I just thought of like well what how how
much better there's more Wildlife but
I'm like how much better is a hike
over there where there's an invisible
line of this is the national park then
over here
yeah it's gone you know yeah exactly
well what about our hike in Zion so we
went to some of the that was tough yeah
what no the major one sure but what
about the hike right out the gate yeah
that was good right the Indian burial
grounds and that one those are also
really good and we saw no one it was
just get out there because that was a
national park that it was too crowded
yeah it was like lines and [ __ ] because
I'm used to Joshua Tree where there's
three entrances and you can just usually
I've never had a problem you just Cruise
right in especially when I go like I do
my hiking at midnight like you know in
this Moonlight it's like ain't nobody
around
so cool sounds like it sounds like a um
who makes who sang tusk Tusk the album
Tusk Fleetwood Mac sounds like a
Fleetwood Mac album I just said title of
the song
um but the sun is aggressive it's
aggressive
um but anyways we ended up hiking Big
Mountain which is also funny because
it's a street sign it just says Big
Mountain like it sounds like it's like
check it out big mountain and uh we did
a great Trail up there the Danny on
trail where you take a gondola back down
kind of like in Ecuador it was pretty
fun and there was a bear sighting on the
gondola right before we go down but we
never saw her back oh
don't you wish you could be one of those
guys that just says you saw things that
you didn't see
are you jealous of people that just make
[ __ ] up sometimes sometimes I am it
makes for a better story like why
include the part that wasn't awesome
yeah why not just be like this [ __ ] it
yeah
it's it's not I agree with it it's like
yeah for the for the story listener's
sake right just say that now we saw a
bear it was crazy oh really yeah he
wasn't close but he was down there he
was crawling around the problem is when
people start asking details you want to
be like hey dude [ __ ] come on man I'm
not it's like when someone says you ever
read that book you've heard the chosen
you're like yeah just because you mean
like get on with your stories and then
they go like what'd you think of the
first job I didn't see it there's a um
Brian Regan told me a great story one
time because we were talking about how
you you make up lies when you're on the
road uh-huh because you don't want to
tell people you're a comedian because
then they want to hear a joke
independent contractor
him and uh his brothers say they're
painters
and it always works but then they went
golfing and they put when you golf two
people they put you with two other
people force them they paired them up
and they realized it was a bad choice
because that works if you're in a cab
but this is a four hour day so naturally
they're like what kind of painters are
you and just that question they were
like uh oh he's like do we paint houses
do we paint paintings do we paint like
you would know even if you're not as
qualified as you said you were you would
still know what kind of painter you are
and they're like impressionist [ __ ]
broad Strokes uh you know do I paint the
you know Madison Square Garden what the
[ __ ] yeah and he's like we're just
horrible we're like I just paint and
they did a regularly I like to paint
but I was saying to him I have one that
I always do that no one's ever pointed
out is stupid but it always works I say
my friend just had a baby
and then he just started laughing he's
like never in my whole life
no no not your job what are you doing in
town my friend just had a baby for job I
say bartender because I understand it I
only know three jobs but I would say
what are you doing tell my friend just
had a baby and he just goes never in my
whole life have I ever got on a plane
and flown to a city because a friend had
a baby and then he's making me laugh
because he's like my friend had a baby
in Omaha next week
and the week after that my friend had a
baby this is July 14th to the 17th at
Kansas City second show added on second
season on Thursday
um what do you say what's your go-to
you're an independent independent
contractor for a while that's when I was
a new comic
now sometimes they will say comic but
I really hate it because also like I
don't want to talk about this with you
I sometimes though I want to like one-up
somebody and then I will say it it is
cool it is a cool job you want
sunglasses you have to I'm not a
sunglasses guy I should have worn a hat
well this umbrella soon will be helpful
no it won't it won't it can tilt it oh
tilt it
oh my God I can't wait for the Tilt it's
gonna [ __ ] up the oh it's unbelievable
that is a life changer yeah the lighting
will be off but deal with it we're back
we're back
um I gotta get a like a screen from
there to there it wouldn't help right
now because it'd be too high but pretty
soon it would be good but I won't be
here this long what does that mean you
sick they're raising the prices so much
uh let me just show everybody this is
not a green screen
what's that mean it means like we're not
on two separate things oh yeah it looks
like
um so where are you gonna go
I don't know upper west side where you
belong everything is up I saw a a
article it said uh Manhattan prices
average up 35 from this time last year
Brooklyn prices up 30 from last year so
there is no immune place no you gotta
yeah I just leave the city or maybe I'll
come down maybe it's over go to Jersey
Shore I'm moving to Jersey Shore bro
people do that but Jersey is awesome
it's beautiful the ocean it's in the
ocean every day I've seen the ocean I
love it I won't downplay it I think it's
amazing how far is the drive hour
that's that's a problem
it's a lot yeah I know somebody moved to
Brazilian moved to Long Island and first
he was just there for the Summers and um
and he was like no I'll drive into spots
and then I did it while I was staying
there while I was looking for apartment
here and I'm like I listened to the
entire The Wall album and I was like
dude there's no way you're driving in
this far it has to be for a major
meeting well but don't you think as we
get older in comedy that
it's quality of spots and you can do
show a real real helpful stuff is doing
like an hour somewhere [ __ ] around I
think it's consistent spots I hear what
you're saying but I do think it's
consistently going up yeah right and
seeing what other Comics are doing
what's what's become hacky I'll see some
of those 90s Comics especially at the
store come in and you could tell like oh
you just been lost on the road you think
this is very original oh yeah and
everybody's doing like a like a [ __ ]
crocodile hunter bit when I started in
1940. but what do you think you can't
see comedy unless you're at the club
everyone posts every [ __ ] joke now
true
you gonna look at those oh I love how
everybody's posting their crowd work and
it's like we all agreed years ago that
this is the easiest dumbest most the
same thing ever and everyone's like yeah
I'll do it the crowd will eventually
understand this is not fun it's only fun
if you're Live Well that's what Ron on
hershberg had the point we all owe Steve
hofsted an apology
everybody was like this guy [ __ ] this
guy because it was like
[ __ ] him and now everyone does this yeah
I [ __ ] my mom screw that guy
now everybody does it yeah
good cigar right very nice smooth light
smooth is my baby's [ __ ] at the end
of these this is the one thing we have
to do I took some some Glamor Shots of
it
um but also when you do these on your
own when you do a two Comics two cigars
on your own by the way if a third person
wants to get in they cannot honestly
it'll only be two counts yeah we have
them with big J Me and Bobby were doing
a big J was like right I would stay
there and you want to say something I'd
hand him the mic but I'm like stay off
screen oh I like that yeah
yeah
um
oh at the end just say would I buy
another one of the would I never buy
another one would I buy another one
would I pay five more or would I buy a
case oh looks like that's the rating
system I believe it's known as a box box
speaking of box look at the little lady
on there with a ponytail that feels
sexual doesn't it on the thing oh
because a ponytail means [ __ ] and
then this is phallic
so it's got a little I think it's a
little uh subliminal there's a young
lady with a ponytail and she's saying
hey suck my dick in depth the top of the
band is like it's got like that and it
has the ponytail lady on it yeah but the
top see the top it's got extra [ __ ] in
there yeah it's like hologramy oh
they're all the ponytail and the
Holograms yeah yes oh yeah kohiba says
damn that's how you do this mean girl it
blows you
if it does
then for sure it's valak
yeah that's the only way to decide well
you know a cigar is phallic in general
anybody [ __ ] on cigar use that you know
that you're like shut up
without saying names but like whenever
you watch UFC someone's like oh it's
just gay like dude it's [ __ ] hacky
stop saying that
oh yeah well Carlin had the great joke
but even Freud says sometimes a cigar is
just a cigar yeah yeah but sometimes
it's a big brown [ __ ] dick
what a view over here it's not bad right
when you go from here uh we'll have a
barbecue at some point when I get back
from Paris maybe you go to Paris yeah
when writing class uh writing Tuesday
yeah I think that should have sailed
you're 60 years old yeah
um why are you taking a writing class in
Paris the guy teaches it there
it's not specific for Paris but that's
where he teaches they give him a weekend
American University in Paris so he
teaches at World pots wow new book
coming out in October you're writing a
book Rolf did I am
what yeah Rolf what Ralph Potts you
wrote a book here's another book coming
out oh he teaches the class but you're
writing a book what about travels yeah
yeah
probably the only interesting thing
about me no your face is gross okay
you're too old to be living in this
neighborhood hanging out with us have
you looked at the upper west it really
feels like you do well there can't walk
home from spots I really love walking
home from spots it's just a nice thing
taking a city bike you're just back
today was the first day I was texting
with Sam Morrell and he was like I think
about moving to the village and I was
like oh it's the worst and he's like I
want to walk to the cellar yeah and it
did hit me like that is nice meanwhile
when he did it I was in traffic on the
Queensborough Bridge being like that's
not bad and then in a store it's time to
sell me on that there's a little place
called Grove 34 that I've been going to
a place called Grove 34. what is that
it's a little comedy venue these two
like alcoholic young comedians that
remind me of myself I mean I don't want
to say they're alcoholics but they're
Party Guys great you can be at that age
yeah and they run the club and it's like
a do-it-yourself thing and it's four
blocks from my house love that so you
should come back we'll smoke a cigar in
the backyard we'll walk over there and
[ __ ] around I get a crowd there wow nice
great you get a crowd there you mean you
tell people I'm performing I can get
like it's like it holds like yeah
Queen's Comedy Room that's what it is
yeah they had that one at the Greek
restaurant
David Taylor's brother ran it oh man
Taylor not Taylor yeah way back yeah and
then they but I remember him saying he's
like there's no comedy out here and
there's a massive audience well there's
QED
that's Christian Finnegan's wife's Club
okay and then there's now Grove 34.
which is great you should come on I'm
doing it August uh oh I made a plug in
here I don't know if this will be out
but maybe August 22nd or something like
that maybe it's a Monday but anyways
I'm walking over there I'm like this is
amazing and it's funny I don't even
click to me that everyone lives near the
cellar and just walks over there I'm
like it's unbelievable I just walked
four blocks and did a comedy show yeah
that's what Matt said because all these
Comics live here so why is there no
place before it does make it easier just
to like walk by but this this
neighborhood's getting too expensive
because the seller it was a shitty
neighborhood before
it's a shitty neighborhood now yeah it's
gross but it's expensive but back then
it wasn't like expense so you could live
around the thing it's like when they
lived at the all those people like uh
Pollock and and uh and uh what's her
name the singer uh Cyndi Lauper Smith
Patty Smith Patty Smith and they all
shared they all lived in the same area
Bohemian yeah they were poor they could
be poor you can't be poor in that area
now no that I mean this has been going
on for a while but yeah in the [ __ ]
60s 70s 80s it was a Bohemian lifestyle
and you could
it was for artists it's like artists
that can't live here they can't live
here so then who comes like they just
get Jeff Coons to come and [ __ ] buy a
[ __ ] floor
would work too
good Jeff Goods is that artist he makes
this giant like uh inflatable balloons
looks like inflatable uh balloon animals
oh he has a bunch of Michael Jackson
ceramic [ __ ] and whatever he's just like
it's gaudy it's gaudy and it's each one
is like 400 000 to buy oh geez um pass
yeah that that's the includes the
Jeffersons I was I was starting at The
Comedy Store like I was brand new comic
this guy Mike Rica he was just talking
to Eleanor and chest she was just a
waitress and he goes he's just [ __ ]
on her on for fun and goes all you
wishes all you want to do is be the next
Mrs Carey that's all you're looking for
and she goes like Jim or Jim
Jeremy what's the other one with the fat
ones Drew Drew Jim or Drew and he goes
you don't care
that's funny
Drew Carey got the best job in Show
Business you know Price is Right
you ever hear about his gig it's Monday
Tuesday Wednesday oh wow from ten to two
two weeks on one week off wow
and it pays like a ton of money wow I
mean what a cake job what a cake job and
for a cool thing too it's like this is
fun and easy nothing has to go into this
it's fun it's whatever a little bit see
you work whatever that is nine days a
month yeah and you're done by 2 p.m and
then 10 a.m most of the show is them
guessing numbers
most of the show you're not doing
anything no you just stand there it's
fun yeah it's fun it's been that way out
oh this guy's old he might not be able
to spin the wheel whoa I used to have we
talked about this I used to have that
thing of like um
you know don't you want to be an artist
man and then you realize I'm like oh
it's just fun experientially I mean
obviously I'm not gonna do commercials
for [ __ ] Exxon Mobil or whatever
because it gets your moral values but
then you're just like instead of just
not not supporting it these celebrity
people you're like hey uh we got you a
Chase Bank commercial it'll take you
five hours it pays 1.5 million and you
start to go ah maybe I'll take care of
my nephew I'll go down there for a few
hours [ __ ] it easy peasy it's like a
corporate gig yeah with Nate in Vegas he
goes uh I'm supposed to hang out with
him in Nashville
and uh I'm coming back from this music
festival I was like Hey so should I go
straight to your house or should I say
the condo one night then go over and he
goes ah [ __ ] I forgot you were coming
I went to Vegas on a corporate gig and I
was like oh I go tell you what though if
you want
fly out here
I have a suite and a [ __ ] we have
private tables and they'll get you
another room and um wow it's up to you
and then we'll fly back together I
already have like a book a string of
flights back so I can just put you on
those if you want to come to Greenville
with me have a kick off dinner with
Becky on and [ __ ] a couple other guys
and um and then go get rental car go
back to or fly back to Nashville from
there and I was like sure I will go wow
you're the only guy that would say
yesterday that's what you really do
that's what he said too
um
um
well I was even talking about that
uh corporate gigs doing corporate gigs
but he did this corporate gig it sucked
but it was enough money to be like let's
have a good time but it's like this is
not a good show right this was like a
bar show and they asked me to do it I'd
be like no right it's all [ __ ] Toyota
people no I don't want to do that show
thanks anyway
yeah sometimes you just do things and
you go hey what the [ __ ] well you
realize you're like I can you feel like
a a corporate schlep would ever be like
I can take this money and do fun things
with it or donate it whatever the [ __ ]
yeah I don't see Nate doing that I see
no golf simulator in his basement
instead he's like this is the one that
Toyota paid for well he's doing well huh
he's doing well see don't you wanna I
wanna do so well that I can have an
apartment in Queens so I'm 12 minutes
from the airport and then a house by the
ocean that would be nice is that too
much to ask for us comedian I wanna I
wanna like a Woods house yeah me too I
think about that I go back and forth you
know ocean and woods it's it's those are
the things okay so wait do we have the
discussion no someone thinks so you have
I think about it all the time a million
dollars to spend five million dollars is
nothing
would you have that five million on
beach house Woods house
Farmhouse or what else is there
I don't know
Outhouse Suburban house outhouse would
be a nice one it's a suburb house
whatever yeah it wouldn't be the suburbs
house but like what would you do would
you go Beach House Mountain House Woods
mountainous Woods well first of all a
million dollars now that's a regular
that's just a house yeah it's crazy I go
to Zillow just because just to [ __ ]
around like a house in Jersey within an
hour of here
is like a million bucks a lot of them I
mean some of them are not not all of
them someone's gonna write to me like
[ __ ] you but like 700 000 but if you
want like a four bedroom two bathroom
like a nice house yeah nice house that's
like a million dollars damn
I met me I was talking to my friend he
was working at the patent office and
then he was going to grad school he
decided to went back to school to go to
grad school and he was like you get paid
more you know and you're more valuable
to like law firms and other firms and
stuff like that plus your experience at
the patent office and I was like what if
they like give you like what are the
panels gives you like a bunch of money
right now he's like what do you mean
like what if they paid you like a
hundred thousand dollars a year this is
my four years out of comedy and he goes
I already make that I was like what no
way even that because I'm normal I'm not
even rich
well here's the thing going back to the
the house in the woods thing yeah a
house in the woods is a little scary you
got to take that into consideration
bears and such bear and and just you
know rapey Murder ghouls like I mean
you're on the second floor in the woods
no one's within I feel like I as you get
older you get more conservative I feel
like I'm like I would want a gun if I
lived in the woods get a gun get two I
don't know if I needed Astoria I have
tools hey that's like a Pearl Jam lyric
got a gun in fact I got to that's okay
because I love God
uh any tits
if you're like in the woods and you're
up in the second floor and you hear
someone breaking in 9-1-1 and that's
gonna take some time you're [ __ ] 700
Acres out somewhere but where O'Neill
found it for me and it was too much I
couldn't afford it it was like 700 000
or something like that and I was like
damn but I like looked into it I'm like
maybe I can really scrounge and reply
myself you know and the lady was like
you can't get a mortgage for this
because there's no like power lines no
water lines no nothing so no one will
give you a mortgage to pay for it out
right try to talk me out of it and she
goes I'll take it up they're like well
show me where it is I can like I can
just go and look at it myself she goes
ah the neighbors aren't
the friendliest oh I was like okay she
goes and just so you know like if you
get bit by a snake you're like an hour
from a hospital yeah
and I'm like lady I'm a buyer all right
well that's nice though but
yeah but the woods I'd like to be near
the wood like Williamstown Massachusetts
is like a it's like near from it's near
a lot of parks I want to be a 10 minute
drive from a small town yes like if I
could be a 15 minute drive from
Terrytown but but deep in the woods
we're like I don't hear anything yeah
yeah that would be great
yeah all right we gotta figure this out
what does this pay a couple hundred this
is a not-for-profit uh YouTube series
well that'll that'll be ads I'll give
I'll give you go Cuba well yeah there's
ads I've already had one yeah like in
addition to this no that was the one
[ __ ]
um
um
yeah I don't know your house but I don't
know it's hard to so where would you go
Beach House people are no beaches
yeah Beach is tough because the
neighbors this is what I want because
all those houses
we talk our friends come over we're
talking rape race I mean you need no
neighbors I don't want people around I'm
tired of people going I do mushrooms I
want to be able to scream I want to be
able to scream you know I mean not not
bother somebody on a Tuesday yeah Woods
is good because I love hiking hiking is
better than ocean hiking yeah I go to
the ocean I'm in there for 12 minutes
because this is the thing with me I love
being in the ocean I hate being on the
beach you really do you're like let's
get back in there I want to I want to
hang in the ocean spiritual the beaches
and spiritual there's music the sand
sucks the ocean is spiritual ocean heals
I stayed at one place on it's like the
last house in uh Northern Ecuador the
last house before the beach and so no
one's really walking by some fishermen
in the morning but you just sit out
there on a deck and just look at the
ocean it was [ __ ] nice but vacation
home there's nothing to do other than
right a hike is something to do but the
ocean is nice in the and what's good in
the winter too but the ocean is good
going down there you walk around right
just feel it you feel small it's good
both are good yeah well this is a very
privileged conversation
pure Cuban cigars and I'm like this how
long is this Jesus
um or wait what about this option we
forgot this option nice high-rise
Florida window ceilings I mean Florida
ceiling Windows yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because those are nice too a nice
outside like not a like a real people
deck not this horse [ __ ]
yeah it's nice to have a little bubble
to be like no homeless guys can get to
me right here I can be outside if you
don't like homeless guys this is not the
neighborhood for you but this bubble
just concentrate on the bubble bubble
yeah I don't know I can't say in New
York forever though Adrian got through
to me she was like we look like [ __ ]
rats my my heat went out for three weeks
and the guy's like I'll cut 50 bucks off
your rent because that's not I put my
heat on I told you when I I lived in
Harlem and uh our refrigerator broke
and my landlord lived across the hall
and I said my refrigerator is broken and
she goes y'all want to put your Cokes in
my fridge and I was like I mean that's
not exactly the show it's like knock on
your door when I want to Coke my my
[ __ ] buzzer wouldn't work stop
working yeah that's not a great solution
and I was like hey dude the [ __ ]
buzzer doesn't work it's attached to my
phone never opens up I can't open it
goes well we talked to everybody else
says work I'm like in 15 minutes you
talk to the other tenants and there's
worked I believe you're lying to me
anyway so the guy was like well if you
want a solution you can have stuff
dropped off like packages dropped off uh
to the office I'm like seven blocks away
no that's not a great solution fix the
buzzer no I like hit 40. my life has
changed I want a driveway yeah look at
like my I have a car which is the most
nice it's the most I've ever spent on
anything it's like my only thing I've
ever bought in my life but I love the
way you bought it too it lives
in a in a [ __ ] Subterranean uh garage
twice as much as my car that's insane
yeah it's insane and also it's like a
half a mile away I gotta walk a half a
mile and wait for somebody like hey it's
not here I'm like [ __ ] yeah I have to
get a stranger to drive it I haven't
seen it
I want a driveway and I want a yard I
sit in my back area it's something I
want to be able to pull into a driveway
how about this this is somebody who's
doing La at least you pull into your
spot you know that's normal to have a
spot in La it's pulling your spot and
then I'm listening to the radio I just
sit there turn the car off I just kind
of sit there and I just like think for a
while you do that at your garage
sir yeah are you supposed to park air
it's a monthly I'm like no no monthly
it's like sir okay leave me alone your
bread Ernst fan yeah I think that guy's
so funny oh he's great why are you
saying that he's got a great bit about
um he's like I want you I I can't do the
voice but he's so funny he's like I
watch HGTV these guys are [ __ ] lit
he's like oh they all take place in
Michigan and Ohio he's like they're
[ __ ] living
the guy he's got a stay-at-home wife
he's like a manager at Johnny Rockets
they're putting in a pool I don't have a
parking space
it's true though we got to move to
Kentucky let's all go to like Northern
Kentucky
in late Austin Louisville Louisville's
not bad it's warm Cincinnati Northern
Kentucky houses there for like 500 000
you can get like a second floor wrap
around porches you can drive an hour
away from Luba in bird's eye Indiana
because it was the Derby where you
couldn't find anything we're just like
gotta [ __ ] a house in the woods sure
it was great an hour away yes and you
could get 30 minutes away if it wasn't
Derby week and you can drive to all
these places you can drive to Nashville
Chicago St Louis the other one that's
how they pushing is pushing us on
Nashville he goes Nashville started
because it was in between Chicago and
New York it was between the west coast
and the East Coast so it wasn't the
longest flights the one he was like you
do have to fly Southwest a lot
that's the only yeah well that's why
Cincinnati I think I think you can get
some Delta [ __ ] going
you left Delta
I'm all about the Delta baby dude I was
in the airport with Norman
Mark Norman very funny comic uh out of
New York most people haven't heard of
him by way of New Orleans
um
he I think what do you think they're
building up they think they're redoing
their deck up there
what are you talking about see that that
the big the furthest right big giant
ground building I know stuff on top I
know who doesn't see it the audience
but no I don't see it either on both of
those actually they have these little
like scaffolding things I feel like
you're tricking me you give me the
finger what I don't know is that one
just over the curb oh I see okay
scaffolding things do you think they're
gonna like totally redo that deck maybe
is that my old apartment
I don't know
anyway so uh Normand get it get there
all right you're at the airport with the
airport and uh he's delayed I saw him
he's supposed to go Minneapolis tonight
before me oh I got this story on the
podcast yeah oh great and I just hung
out and it got canceled yeah I saw him
I'm going a day early so I'm like I fly
late you know get their daily no stress
especially I had to kind of fly Chicago
the next day so I don't want three days
in a row flying and um
and I see me they were like hi Mark I
was like oh [ __ ] dude wait what your
show is tonight my Show's tomorrow it's
4 P.M I've been all day he went from
Newark to [ __ ] LaGuardia brutal and
then we hung out for a while but he was
like I had that new Delta pass and he
goes maybe I can get you in maybe they
go you have a few you have a few
um get buy one get ones you know get a
friend in and they go do you want to use
one of your passes and in in new Mark
fashion he didn't cheap out on it oh wow
he was like yeah let's use it nice yeah
it was great that was changing he really
is now when he steals like something
from the super supermarket he gets
something for you too oh that's nice
that's nice Shame Shame Works she's got
a really shame people dude we're all uh
we're all uh me and I don't know where
we were with Becky Owen and him driving
somewhere
oh maybe uh souljils and uh we stop to
the rest stop and I see him with his
like a thing of almonds and I could just
see it in his eyes because I'm I'm just
like him he's stealing that he's gonna
steal that sure and he's looking for an
out how do I get out of the place you
know how do you make sure no eyes are on
you and I just it was perfect every once
in a while you [ __ ] nail something I
was like Mark Mark Mike needs us right
now we gotta Market he needs us in a
[ __ ] lot now he's like oh [ __ ] what
and I fooled him he goes what is it I'm
like no I just you're gonna steal that
right he goes oh that's pretty good dude
it's pretty good yeah thanks not bad
I got the Delta plus one I just I just
paid outright at the beginning of the
year give me the Delta plus one and what
does that mean it's 800 for the for the
lounge it's 800 bucks for the year but
it pays for itself because if you want
to have breakfast at the airport yeah
yeah cup of coffee five so you get free
coffee meals it is a no waiting in line
in the [ __ ] with the chat then you
can get to the airport early I try to
get there where I want to get there so
late that as I'm ringing in the the lady
behind the camera's like oh okay
I like to get there early I go to the
lounge I'm like I go to the lounge have
a cup of tea eat read I'm starting to
see it now but I just can't justify
paying it I guess I could just pay for
the day it's like 50 bucks right to just
get out it's 800 bucks but you fly a lot
don't you I do fly a lot but I don't get
there early enough but then also they
get you right don't they say hey your
flight's boarding go out go now they
don't get you but they tell when you
check in they say it's about an eight
minute walk and it leaves it's on time
so right okay yeah what about delay do
they say like flight 264 or Mr Norman
now time for you to leave yeah but you
get updates on your phone and [ __ ] can
you get that everywhere or just Delta
like when you're overseas can you get
like is there any like uh Delta is part
of the um Global Alliance and in Europe
everything's better in Europe it's not
like hitlerism a little bit yeah
but good we were the alliance I don't
know if you oh yeah yeah that was us the
axis of Evil yeah that was uh Italy
Japan Germany and uh I bet they were
like the Republicans why didn't we get
any say on this we're not evil we're
trying to rid the Jews out of this
[ __ ] planet I know
nobody thinks they're evil I think
they say that's an acting role we need
to play Hitler you have to play it as if
you think you're doing the right thing
right you can't judge him if you're
going to act him because you can't be
like I'm really shitty what I'm doing
that's a pretty bird over there
I heard a um oh yeah what time is it
holy [ __ ] what time is it am I late for
what my spots no no sunset's 8 30.
what time is your first spot eat
something right
6 24 6 24. hey
I could wrap it up
wrap up your [ __ ] with my mouse
yeah we could totally that's a good
excuse that both of those are good
reasons if I can turn this off not bad
how often do you think about death daily
once a week once a month once a year
almost never now I did have a therapist
uh psychologist whatever the one that
prescribes drugs did a little bit of
like hey think about this think about
this but mostly just like let's get you
the right drugs
um
and uh he was like so how's it kicking
in like you know whatever's like I'm
feeling better and he goes do you feel
something about suicide I was like I
think about the idea of suicide but I no
longer think about doing it myself but
it's still an interesting topic if you
don't do it yourself it's not suicide
that's one of the key components and he
goes let's wait until you're not
thinking about suicide at all really and
then we'll say cured uh because he goes
most people just generally don't think
about it on a day to day yeah I think
about it all the time it's so
interesting do you think about death a
lot
I do but now in a much more positive way
I used to be hanging out and be like
we're gonna die that's awful most of my
life take me that the darkness take me
now I think we're gonna die but we're
not right now we're live right now it's
quite a gift look at all these colors
you can see it's like it's almost over
enjoy it it's like that last day of
sleep away camp privilege you're like
let's make let's make this count the
last week when you're traveling I never
did sleep awake yet but I see you when
you're visiting Ecuador sure oh you're
[ __ ] a lot that wasn't the best
example oh God I was dying
I was dying I got so emotion I couldn't
stop crying it was bad it was crazy I
mean that was that was bad crying from
poop
well it may be emotion because I was
everything was coming out of me you know
you get very vulnerable
it wasn't like I took a couple of shits
I mean I was like stop I was non-stop
[ __ ] first it was almost comical we
stopped at a rest stop it was a gas
station not even a rest stop a gas
station Ecuador Countryside they're not
known for their excellent bathrooms in
there no in their in their gas stations
and then like drive 10 minutes like I
already gotta stop for poop like come on
dude no way your [ __ ] rectum's still
going in from the last one no I would
[ __ ] and then come out literally get in
the car and be like we got to stop at
the next one it was so bad
so bad well I drank a full cup of
Ecuadorian faucet water
it was great glad that happened at the
end not the beginning yeah exactly well
Sarah had bad ships but during a hike
which was brutal it almost is worse she
had it during the hike with us yes the
whole hike she was sweating she was
dying wow we got to that River she held
it and she finally she made it yeah but
she thought she was gonna shoot up she
had like [ __ ] your pants sweats where is
this is a mural of Ecuador where's uh
where we went window I don't know me no
the toucan I think I think it's reversed
East-West does it mean no you're right I
mean no mean no yeah because that's
Galapagos that's the mountains we're
just over the mountains yeah it's that
that's that's our area that's the toucan
we saw I thought we should have been uh
in the mural
because that's part of our experience
yeah I mean it's just Florida
yeah floral and fauna yeah and Bandit
with Bandit Bandits down underneath
there oh there's looking at it no that's
a tapiary taper taper who is Sarah
that's monkey these are funny visuals if
maybe you can plug them in or something
yeah maybe
um
all right Joe I think we've reached
towards the end of our cigar yeah I'm
done talking to you so
[Music]
didn't go out it was smooth I'm glad we
have an excuse if you have a fine cigar
I think you tell what you think you have
you have a reason to light up that fine
cigar a friend you haven't seen in
Forever is in town a [ __ ] uh
my friend just did a [ __ ] movie
feature uh that he wrote and starred in
and produced and produced
the Jew side and um and uh and what a
special occasion so why not have a
special cigar yes I maybe have two I
remember yeah we could have another one
something else
um I remember when um when uh your
wedding Bobby brought a box of uh oh
it's one of my biggest regrets in my
life the judge judges
Our Father it was in my father I think
it might have been judge it was it my
father that'll be coming on this episode
oh my God it was so bad that's all I
smoked normally my father what was so
bad he gave me a box like a 300 box of
cigars
I'm like an idiot I just started hand
them out like Santa Claus
and an hour later there was like nine
twenty five dollar cigars with like an
eighth of an inch all over the floor
every [ __ ] person was like yeah give
me a cigar it was ruining your wedding
it's so stupid it's ruining your mindset
everyone's just putting them down
everyone's coughing spitting them out
and I'm like I mean like half the box
was gone I'm like I'm a [ __ ] we
needed a second box of just [ __ ] cigars
it would have been like if Bobby handed
me 300 cash and I ripped up two of the
hundred dollar bills and threw on the
ground you were like what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] it was so stupid like Norman
took one Stavros took one I think my
uncle grabbed one but I'm here when I'm
here I was on Montauk with I was smoking
cigars and Jordan Rose was like oh I've
won I was like okay
um yeah this is a good one for you man
it's just like you're not getting a fine
one it's a good point somebody said that
before who was that was that Bobby that
had that idea it's like you always bring
that was you you always bring a couple
of [ __ ] cigars to him maybe it was
Bennington I can't remember
very giving great guy but yeah he said
you always have a couple of whatever
firecrackers to give to Ari you guys
always have a couple lesser cigars that
you hand to a guy who's like I'll smoke
a cigar yeah somebody smoking is holding
a box and I was like what are you
smoking he's like look here you can have
one he was he brought him to hand out
he's that kind of guy on the walk over
to Dakota oh that's not what I was
trying to do and I actually had a case
of cigars on me not a case but those
like travel cases yeah and I was like oh
here man
thanks a lot I've heard of him you know
he's kind of a legend I've never met him
before yeah he's a tabernacle a good
cigar he goes oh yeah thanks oh he was
grateful and uh yeah he carried that box
like on stage he carried it everywhere
so it was like a book like his first day
of school great guy great comment very
Zen guy yeah he gave me the best advice
of my life he was smoking a cigar
outside so if you think about it just do
it that's exactly it he told you we
would I was doing this stupid contest at
Caroline's years ago which actually led
to me getting live at Gotham and
whatever but we were outside and he
smoking a cigar and I was like oh I was
very nervous Nelly then and he said if
you can somehow wrap your head around
how insane and unfair and frustrating
this business is and accept all of it
you can have a really nice life as a
comedian it was very helpful wow yeah
that's true it's better than any other
job and all that [ __ ] happens in
every job I was in a I was watching a
showcase Carla Bove uh R.I.P was uh was
showcasing for a Showtime series of half
hours
2005-ish four maybe and um and there
were some showcases at the comedy store
then the Showcase of the Improv he was
doing the Improv when I went there to
see him and I saw the whole thing you
know
um and then I was in the bathroom peeing
and two Executives from Showtime maybe
an executive and a producer were peeing
so I could hear them remember that you
know the Improv bathroom yeah you're
washing your hands you could totally and
they were like what do you think of it
was two black comics and they were only
going to book one and they're like what
do you think of comic a or comic B and
they go well comic B crushed he had a
way better set and they're like yeah
like but comic Haze he's a little bigger
name was and they're like yeah let's go
with kamakay and it was like what's the
point of even showcasing yes he had no
chance he crushed it right
and it was like oh and then when you do
that it's like oh okay whatever yeah
exactly do your best I'm sure it'll
happen and we're living in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] balcony in New York pretty nice
I don't live here but thank God but
Colin Quinn always helps me too he goes
reminds you that because everyone always
goes Showbiz Show Business this show
business day goes every profession is
that way yeah if you're a plumber you're
like that guy's [ __ ] doing the
plumbing
job that guy sucks yes he uses awning
there's his pipes he's just hot he's a
Jew that's why they gave it to him oh
yeah
it's my biggest uh fear for white Comics
is it before when we weren't succeeding
it was because we wish weren't good yet
and now I've heard it all these white
counts like oh cause I'm a white guy and
you're like ah but actually that wasn't
a good set you had yeah and now you're
gonna blame it on these other things
other than yourself right it's not a
good place for growth oh we gotta go to
that chicken place we should go to the
chicken place okay yes yeah I'm starving
what time is it
what time is your spot ate what
8 30 8 30. okay and let's stop and get
some ice cream too yes walk over there
yes one of my favorite things is walking
from the old stand to one of those ice
cream places on like 11th or 13th and
just late at night in the summer
I think it was the old stand and just
walking down there getting some ice
cream walking back in our high we had an
hour making spots and it was just like
what a fun New York I was new to New
York I was excited to hang out with New
York comics and it was it was still cool
we knew each other but probably when I
saw you in ducked and ran the other way
I think it's past that I was talking
about hurtful I woke up in a cold sweat
from that that was bad I didn't know you
I'm not good with new people I'm a shy
guy
I would love to say like still but it's
like I've been there a thousand percent
of course it's like ah that was like I
forget what comic was like living here
for six months I was like I gotta meet
him and [ __ ] you know you might have to
meet them like you know that curb
enthusiasm when uh Cheryl when he's
still married to her Cheryl yeah and he
goes ah she goes I saw the dentist I
invited him over dinner invited the
dinosaur for dinner and he's like
walking up says like why we have a
business relationship she goes oh this
is nice she goes and he takes two more
steps he goes
I find a new dentist now
it's just like I won't be able to go to
him if I haven't seen my home he just
hit him it's just like [ __ ] he is the
one and only king of comedy he really is
the king
I owe everything to him that's a good
way to wrap up right it is um okay would
you buy one of these it just went out
too one of these five of them
none or a box it means you're talking
too much if it went out
um I'd buy a box I mean I'd buy a box I
would buy a Boxley there's a [ __ ]
killer this is one of my favorite cigars
I've ever had in my life I agree I agree
I think it's a no-brainer box no brainer
box yeah I like that term
I will say at the wedding giving out
cigars the the point is not to everybody
to smoke them is the point is just like
hey isn't this fun here's cigars it was
gone before you got him you should get
married just for the party
it's not a bad idea I could just have a
party that's a good point um but I like
the series I like the suits
no I I you can't do a just a random
Party In terms right right I think I was
having a party in tear down like and
[ __ ] yourself people won't show up
that's what's nice about a wedding
everybody you love is like [ __ ] we gotta
go we gotta go Norman's like I cancel
spots for this like why did you call in
I know well that's that's yeah that's
that's old mark
um what it's old Norman
you think he's yeah I think there's an
80 chance he doesn't show up to the
bachelor party and I'm not kidding or he
goes ah my flight's laid oh geez
80 percent
well that'll show up to 80 to miss the
wedding some of it it's just like he
doesn't know I was just like tell all
these comments like use your calendar
and your iPhone well I can't commit just
put it in there so that if something
comes up just go oh actually no this is
not more important than that can we do
another week well this is how did you
get the offer I have this with Mark all
the time I'm sorry it's bad with it too
sometimes I'll go like this all right so
we're gonna record Tuesday noon and he
goes great
and I go how come you're not doing
anything right now why didn't you write
something down you didn't open your
phone what's going on there yeah that's
the best last time I was coming here I'm
like yeah I got a Mark and I are
recording you go Mark and I are going to
the Yankee game and I'm like well I got
bad news for you and then he just goes
to me I knew it too because I had the
inside information and I was like hey
Matt so we'll meet over there about six
o'clock or whatever like right before I
get 12 o'clock we'll meet up they get
it's like no response I'm like I know I
know that's Charming
we just got to know what you're dealing
with and then you're fine but anyway I
would agree I'd buy a box of these 300
even 500 just to have a box of These
Fine Cohibas for them in the box yeah
send us about Johnny kahiba from Cuba
not the American version
wow the only way to get Cubans in uh in
Ecuador was to they were so expensive
with the taxes they're non-negotiable
you couldn't get them is to have someone
going to Cuba visit home and goes which
there are a lot of those and then say
bring something back for me hmm
that story sucked yeah
all right
two commas two cigars guys don't forget
to hit subscribe at least some comments
for the algorithm uh or or suggest your
favorite cigars or I don't know what
else do they leave in the comments the
story of when list sucks oh yeah yeah
definitely do that only the only reason
you're gonna see those because we're
asking for it yeah this is a [ __ ]
idiot [ __ ] him maybe if you had
right when you had it on the comments I
don't know just to have a fun group have
a fun [ __ ] conversation up there
maybe let's make this podcast uh comment
section a [ __ ] not podcast YouTube
series let's make it a fun place fun
place yeah yeah
all right thanks buddy it was great